AND IT WILL BE MET
FORCEFULLY.
AND WHEN I WILL NOT SAY
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE TALKING
ABOUT TIMING.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT EARLIER
TONIGHT DURING A MEETING
WITH MILITARY LEADERS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE DISCUSSING HOW
TO RESPOND TO THE LATEST
CHEMICAL ATTACKS IN SYRIA.
THAT HAS NOW LEFT AT LEAST
40 DEAD.
HERE WITH REACTION, POLICY
GROUP VICE PRESIDENT CIA
SENIOR INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
DANIEL HOFFMAN, FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT.
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST DR. GORKA.
MR. HOFFMAN, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS REGION
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND.
YOU WORKED THERE QUITE A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
>> I DID.
I WAS CHIEF OF THE E.COLI'S
MIDDLE EAST OPERATIONS FOR A
FEW YEARS FROM 2010 TO 14.
MR. PROSECUTE WE DELIVERED
STARK ASSESSMENT ABOUT HOW
SYRIA WOULD BE TRANSFORMED
INTO A PETRI DISH OF
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE ARE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT
RUSSIA, IRAN AND SYRIA HAVE
THIS SORT OF AXIS OF EVIL
TOGETHER TARGETING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS AND THE
OPPOSITION.
RUSSIA CLAIMS TO BE THERE TO
FIGHT ISIS.
BUT THAT'S REALLY NOT THEIR
PURPOSE AT ALL.
>> Sean: YEAH, THAT'S A GOOD
POINT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS
THE ASSAD REGIME AND WEREN'T
THEY SUPPOSED TO GET RID OF
THOSE WEAPONS?
>> THEY WERE -- IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY THE ASSAD REGIME.
THEY HAVE ALLEGEDLY LAUNCHED
AT LEAST 8 CHEMICAL WEAPONS
ATTACKS THIS YEAR USING
SARIN AND CHLORINE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
ELIMINATED THEIR STOCKPILE
BACK IN JUNE OF 2014 BY THE
AGREEMENT THAT YOU
HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER.
AND, OF COURSE, AS WE KNOW,
THE ASSAD REGIME ISN'T GOING
TO BE HELD TO THOSE SORTS OF
AGREEMENTS.
AND THEY KEPT CERTAINLY
ENOUGH CHEMICAL WEAPONS TO
LAUNCH THESE SORTS OF
ATTACKS.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
THEM PAY FOR IT ALSO NEED TO
MAKE RUSSIA AND IRAN PAY FOR
IT BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE TWO
COUNTRIES ENABLING SYRIA
ULTIMATELY IN THEIR TACK
KICK CALL AND STRATEGIC
OBJECTIVES.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, LET ME
GET YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID WE WOULD
KNOW AFTER THE FACT.
ALMOST LIKE IT'S A
CERTAINTY.
I DO NOT BLAME THEM.
DID HE ACT BEFORE WHEN THE
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES AROSE
IN 2017.
>> LOOK, IF WE DON'T
ACCEPTED THE VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT THIS CANNOT BE
DONE AGAIN, OTHERS WILL USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
WE HAVE INTERNATIONAL
TABOOS, INTERNATIONAL
TREATIES, RUSSIA BROKE ONE
DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BY
ININVESTIGATING ANOTHER
COUNTRY AND TAKING ITS
TERRITORY FOR ITSELF.
THAT ADMINISTRATION DID
PRACTICALLY NOTHING.
NOW WE HAVE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
USED AGAINST WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
THE PRESIDENT, I GUARANTEE
YOU IN THE NEXT 24 HOURS, 48
HOURS WILL SEND A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE AS
MR. HOFFMAN SAID, NOT JUST
TO ASSAD BUT TO HIS SPONSORS
AND HIS BACKERS TO RUSSIA,
TO IRAN, EVEN TO CHINA AND
NORTH KOREA THAT WOULD EVER
THINK ABOUT USING THESE
WEAPONS AGAINST INNOCENT
PEOPLE.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT 2003.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT INVASION.
THIS IS ABOUT CHEMICAL
WEAPONS USE.
>> Sean: NEXUS BETWEEN
POLITICS AND NATIONAL
SECURITY IS INTERSECTING
TONIGHT.
AND I EVEN KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE ON NTSB NEWS THAT
HAVE SUGGESTED EVEN THOUGH
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED LONG
BEFORE ANY NEWS ABOUT
MICHAEL COHEN THAT HE WOULD
MAKE A DECISION WITHIN 24 TO
48 HOURS, THEY ACTUALLY USED
THE TERM ON CONSPIRACY TV
NTSB, WAG THE DOG.
>> IT'S REPREHENSIBLE.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO SAY THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS COLLUDING
WITH RUSSIA AND THAT THE
PRESIDENT WORKS FOR VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
WHEN FOR THE LAST 15 MONTHS
EVERY SINGLE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY DECISION COMING OUT
OF THE OVAL OFFICE WITH
REGARDS TO RUSSIA HAS BEEN
BAD FOR THAT KGB OFFICE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WHETHER IT'S THE XL
PIPELINE, ARMING UKRAINIANS,
INCREASING OUR DEFENSE
BUCKET.
ALL OF IT, THEY LIVE IN A
FANTASY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEIR
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS
UNDERMINES OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THESE ISSUES CLINICALLY.
UNEMOTIONALLY AND THROUGH A
LENS THAT LOOKS AT IT AS IF
IT IS REALITY.
NOT SAME KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
ECHO ECHO CHAMBER BEN RHODES
WAS PROUD OF.
REMEMBER THE ECHO CHAMBER?
>> Sean: MR. HOFFMAN, I
AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT
INASMUCH AS WE CAN'T BE THE
WORLD'S POLICEMEN, THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES, I DON'T THINK
AMERICA CAN FIGHT WARS
ANYMORE AFTER THE EXPERIENCE
IN IRAQ WHERE 'IT BECOMES
POLITICIZED AFTER THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS GIVE LIVES AND
LIMBS, WASHINGTON DECIDES
NEVER MIND WE DON'T FIGHT
WARS TO WIN THEM.
WE PUT RIDICULOUS RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT ON OUR BRAVE MEN
AND WOMEN.
DECIDING IN WASHINGTON NOT
ON THE GROUND WHAT TO DO.
SAME THING IN VIETNAM WE
LOST 58,000 PEOPLE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN MOMENTS
WHERE IT'S ONLY THE UNITED
STATES.
ARE WE GOING TO SIT BACK?
DO WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION WHEN WE SEE
IMAGES OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN
BEING GASSED TO STOP IT AND
PREVENT IT?
>> WE DO.
WE HAVE GOT A MORAL
OBLIGATION ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S A VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL NORMS.
AND WE DO NEED TO TAKE
ACTION.
WE ALSO HAVE A STRATEGIC
REQUIREMENT, TOO, TO SUPPORT
OUR ALLIES IN THE REGION.
ISRAEL, JORDAN AND LEBANON.
NOT TO MENTION EUROPE WHICH
HAS BEEN IMPACTED SO
SEVERELY BY THE MIGRATION
CRISIS.
ALL THE INACTION FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEARS REALLY
RESULTED IN THE MASSIVE
LEVEL OF THREATS TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
AND I THINK WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROBABLY
THINKING ABOUT ON JOHN
BOLTON'S FIRST DAY IS WHAT
ARE OUR OPTIONS?
ONE OF THEM CERTAIN SOLID TO
LAUNCH AN ATTACK ON A SYRIAN
AIR BASE.
AND I THINK WE WILL DO THAT
SECONDLY, DO WE SET UP SAFE
ZONES FOR THE POPULATION?
AND THIRD, WOULD WE GO EVEN
FARTHER AND RESUME
ASSISTING, ARMING ANTI-ASSAD
OPPOSITION SO WE HAVE A
LITTLE MORE SKIN IN THE
GAME?
>> WHAT ABOUT RUSSIA SAYING
YOU KNOW RUSSIA WELL.
WHAT ABOUT RUSSIA SAYING
THEY DIDN'T DO IT.
>> I WATCHED THE RUSSIAN
NEWS, SEAN, AND I WATCH IT
EVERY DAY, AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY CALLED IT FALSE NEWS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
YOU KNOW, THEY DENY THAT
THEY HAVE USED THE NERVE
AGENT AGAINST THE DEFECTOR.